no no what's the matter
nothing
are you sure we didn't get off what's
wrong no I'm swinging about the party
yesterday it was good wasn't it it was
fine why what's wrong well you took a
shine to that architect guy didn't you
what Steven that guy in the leather
jacket well I don't know his name do I
because I wasn't introduced to him oh
sorry I didn't know I was real personal
party chaperone
well interesting was he good
conversation like it was flowing full of
adjectives and verbs and I can stir why
is he gonna lever jacket on anyways
boiling in the house maybe he came on a
bike but are you jealous because I had a
conversation with someone is that what
this is about
oh my god it is isn't it well variously
well it's different like it was it all
the way around and I'm talking to some
fit sultry girl in the corner and
clearly I'm in a better time than around
with you for the past month like a blast
tall him off to Disneyland or something
that it's not how I looked and then
every time you look over I'm looking
back at you just like like no don't
injure oh my god that is not what I was
doing exactly are you looking that it's
not I'm sorry but you don't own every
single second of my life if I go
swimming with Kate you don't get like
this if I get pissed with Jeana you
don't turn into a nutter so I'm sorry
what is the difference is obviously
different no I had a conversation with a
man at a party it's not like I've left
on the back of this guy's bike and I'm
definitely not right now it's not about
the bike
I'm here with you because it's where I
want to be sometimes I'm not really sure
why it's not where of can leather jacket
for god sake what's up what you mean
what's up what what Melanie yes Melanie
no no way
you were staring at her tits for like
the whole night how could you tell if I
was staring at a tissue give us out of
the room I could have told if I was on
the other side of the [ __ ] planet it
was so obvious
- honey
he was
you